va bene senti amico mio facciamo così di
vivere un'altra volta
salutami i miei amici e non di e lì dove
mi nascondo ragazzi ci sono dei tizi
chiodi e chiudi mi sono fatto in tempo
dopo della porta alla prima pole rimane
inizio perché tutti tentano di uccidermi
sto posto di merda cerca degli oggetti
da spingere si chiude chiudi la porta
l'inizio spingi porca [ __ ] spinge in
sembra tutorial di un parto ragazzi però
sono riuscito a scappare
ci sarà un'altra strada cazzo andiamo
chi è che lo sta dicendo tu archi a
[ __ ] raga mistero ma perché vogliono
uccidermi cosa vogliono da me è chiuso
fatto io
porca senti zio scusami se ti disturbo
continua pure a dormire sul lettino ma
quando chiudere ragazzi posso fare non
so perché mi stanno seguendo gli
stupratori non ne ho idea comunque
buongiorno sono fa vj non volevo
disturbati attento che arrivano dei tizi
è insomma io me ne vado perché se non
c'è non ci tengo essere stuprato tutto
qua
abbiamo fatto vero sì bene così no cazzo
rai che sono ovunque
dio mio come faccio a scappare di sì sì
sì sì già faccio già faccio da qualche
parte da qualche parte 9 qui salta salta
salta salta
sì sì cazzo ce l'ho fatta mio dio
ragazzi è stata la cosa più assurda di
sempre cioè io non ho mai fatto una cosa
del genere e soprattutto non pensavo di
riuscirci al primo tentativo ancora cioè
famiglia che spunta ma basta
ma quanti cazzo di porta ci sono mio dio
posso nascondermi invece amico mio posso
ma perché calcio motivo no ma mio zio
scavalca fa qualcosa sì non ci credo si
è fatta ma dove cazzo sono passato da me
i miei soldi ma chi cazzo vuoi da me
cioè non ti ho rubato nulla io ragazzi
ma perché c'è gente che mi segue
imperterrita cioè conto di quando avanti
così spiegate non lo so se qualche cela
giorno 6 1 il loro vero presto santa su
ragazzi c'è qualcuno che ha un cervello
in sto posto non ci posso credere
sì sì sì ce l'ho fatto avere adesso
perché mi sono di nuovo
ok senti amico mio io non ti ho fatto
nulla se il più brutto degli altri un po
di palestra non ti farebbe male ok ci
siamo tieni sempre le braccia le gambe
all'interno dell'abitacolo ragazzi mi
sto mi sta legando la sedia un drogato
chi cazzo è no ragano perché sono che
cazzo sta succedendo ragazzi chi è sto
tizio mi sembra mi sembra red di
penombra cioè era uno che tentava di
aiutarmi ma alla fine era uno stronzo di
merda praga dove dove siamo chi bussa
d'uscita c'è l'uscita non ci credo ad
onorare di montagna che c'è costo di
notte questi dati è sì un po le gambe
se vuoi darmi una mano si perché
evidentemente sto cercando fai pure ti
aspetto qui coraggio fatto una bella
corsetta non offrendo va bene non
perdere mai di vista l'obiettivo mi
piace d'accordo di qua i ragazzi che
cazzo uscita vera russi da porca [ __ ]
non mi dire che mi stai portando suo
brutto stronzo di merda lavati cazzo sei
sporco ragazzi mi sembra un androide di
dragon ball comunque sto qui
va beh c'era c'era l'uscita ma noi
ovviamente non ci andiamo perché c'è un
tizio che non si sa perché ci ha legato
alla sedia uccidimi uccidimi cosa non
uccidermi richiesta dicendo uccidimi
amico stai calmo tanto la lingua non ci
serve più a niente ragazzi arrivati
cazzo questo tizio c'è ma è questo che
lega tutta la gente la tortura
diciamo che mi ero proprio stancato di
recare i francobolli era meglio se
continuare alle carni secondo me
comunque va bene siamo e ve ne ha
portato grazie per essere venuto
inizieremo il consulto fra un istante
ragazzi dobbiamo fuggire di qua in
qualche modo grazie no la videocamera no
bastardo mi serve un secondo per darmi
la ripescata e poi potremo parlare
la videocamera mi serve brutto maledetto
strada cosa vuoi fare
ragazze paranormal la vuole registrare
una puntata di paranormal activity
registra le mie liberati cazzo liberty
liberati va sai tutto quel tempo che è
passato con padre manti mi preoccupa un
po chi cazzo è padre martin non lo so
raga
liberiamoci oddio quelli non sono
coltelli da cucina spero che non avrei
permesso di con fondative idee con tutte
quelle stronzate religiose amico mio non
fare cazzate
sia chiaro non ho niente contro di lui
ma a volte mi è sembrato un pazzo
devi rubare a 1 per pagare un altro non
si scappa è un omicidio nella sua forma
più semplice ma che succedevano finisce
tutto il denaro o no succede che ti fico
il calcio nei [ __ ] se non ti stai
zitta non mi liberi subito
beh il denaro diventa una questione di
fede ecco perché sono qui per farti
credere con quella non cita gli la carta
vero cazzo cosa fa
che cazzo fame non ti distrarre mica
vista lei svenendo e devi ancora
assorbire un sacco di concetti vista
tagliando le mani
porca [ __ ] ma che cazzo fa ragazzi
ma che cosa brutta è sto gioco ma che
schifo
oddio fatto ora va meglio vero è capito
lo abbiamo fatto abbiamo trasformato
consumatori in un produttore questa cosa
si venderà da sola che cazzo 20 dai mie
dita marmi ha tagliato due dita ragazzi
non so perchè l'ha fatto che schifo
porca [ __ ]
dimmi che posso liberarmi ti prego dimmi
che possa mia mi ha tagliato due dita mi
servono non riesco a premere i tasti
sennò mi sono liberato non so come ma
non c'è più due dita non vomitare ti
prego stai calmo
qualcosa mi dice che è me l'aspettavo
porca [ __ ]
senti lo so che ti fa male ma siamo
riusciti a c'è non c'è più le dita come
cazzo fai uso alla videocamera lo so io
vi giuro ragazzi e questa è stata una
delle scene più violente che io abbia
mai visto in un videogioco cioè non ho
mai visto una scena così ma alla fine mi
ha lasciato lì non mi sono liberato
pensava veramente che non sarei riuscito
a liberarmi
non sono un paziente sono dirigente
d'azienda come lui non hai proprio
l'area la dirigente d'azienda e tra
l'altro ti manca il birillo non so se te
l'ha tagliato dilaga devo deve uscire al
suo posto di merda scusami se non ti
libera ma ho di meglio da fare comunque
se vuoi
cazzo ha ragione sto arrivando veramente
porca [ __ ] dare sempre ascolto ai
pazzi maniaci perché hanno ragione che
arrivi a di qui la che devo riuscire a
fuggire in qualche modo la scienza la
scienza l'ascensore scappa di sotto ci
servono a chiede per usare l'ascensore
non mi prendete per il culo non mi
prendete per il culo non scherzate vero
mio dio mi serve una chiave ce la posso
fare posso fuggire da qui sopra anche se
c'è del sangue non mi frega vabbè
l'importante che sia fuggito lo che il
tizio che stava arrivando di nuovo mi
sembra vi giuro pensavo che mi stesse
prendendo per il culo ma qualcosa mi
dice che invece davvero cd le porte
grazie anche l'altra anche l'altro anche
l'altro anche l'altra grazie mille
arrivederci porca [ __ ]
usciamo di qui malizia dimmi che si apre
qualche porta non si apre un cazzo visto
jobs no no no cazzo cazzo non inseguire
con quella cesoie di merda infilate le
nike a pranzi carri praga dove stiamo
andando non lo so sto correndo a caso
praticamente non so dove sto andando
deve raggiungere la [ __ ] no di qua
sono arrivato chicca chi sei tu
se mi tocchi ancora giuro non so che
cosa jury ma non mi interessa chiuditi
chiuda cazzo si chiama è da qualche
parte dove appare nei cessi nei cessi in
eccessi nei gessi scari allora prima ho
detto che scaricarsi non era una bella
idea ma qualcosa mi dice che adesso
serve posso saltare da un cesso
all'altro il prezzo gioco qualcuno vince
perché uno perde non faccio io le regole
ma tanto sono poi sono scappato nella
processo non sa dove sono
perché questa è chiusa a chiave raga
senza rumori bruttissimi mio dio lo so
prima avrei dovuto tagliarti i piedi è
stato un errore ragazzi laga non ho idea
di dove sia finito ma io scavalco per
sicurezza pre impostati sinistro del
mouse dei ragazzi qualcuno di voi poi
gentilmente spiegarmi perché c'è uno
squilibrato che tenta di scortarmi la
faccia o cose del genere
no perché sinceramente ancora non l'ho
capito dove cazzo andato non lo so
porca [ __ ] non ai danni per del
perché continui a seguire ha sfondato la
porta poi non ho capito come mai tu
povero ragazzi ce l'ho fatta e stato
assurdo
cioè non ai tagli come cazzo abbia aprì
la porta brutto stronzo che ho ha detto
rega ce l'ho fatta posso farcela
posso baciato gli sta roba dove cazzo
sia infiniti 4 ma [ __ ] pure tu
stai zitto che c'è un tizio che ci serve
che non è neanche tanto pacifico ragazzi
siamo storto sclerando vi giuro
pressiamo adesso raga dog cos'è sto
cos'è ci sono un po di cessi mio dio
e vabbè almeno come posso nascondere
abbastanza ragazzi io non so se quel
tizio può entrare qui dentro mi sa di sì
cosa aspettate un attimo
ok allora fermi riflessione pausa
accesso ma il team [ __ ] ragazzi è
bene e meglio tirare di cui prima che ci
faccio un culo nero ecco lo sapevo porca
[ __ ] [ __ ] ragazzi e vabbè è
impossibile è impossibile
perché deve rincorrere solo me ma
l'edizione cos'è questo via via via via
via si si si
non ci credo [ __ ] dopo secoli di
di tentativi ma mio dio ci avrò passato
mezz'ora è a dir poco mezz'ora ghazi ce
l'ho fatta
andiamo avanti di qua perché mio dio
sono esausto dove dove stiamo andando di
preciso non lo so raga qualsiasi posta è
meglio di quel nome lo ritrova davanti
sono sicuro cos'è quella è la mia ombra
grazie a dio racca dove dove son finito
vabbè ragazzi dovunque sia finita è
comunque un posto migliore di colori
prima questo è sicuro
noi proseguiamo non me lo trovo davanti
sono convinto che cazzo siamo ragazzi mi
sono completamente perso non so dove
sono
dopo ne andiamo di qua scavalco le
finestre cos'è quello la chiave
dell'ascensore ragazzi dobbiamo uscire
dove dov'è quel pezzente dov'è lo so che
sto sfondandolo posso sentire male dove
dove cazzo porchio a [ __ ] ok bene bene
così ragazzi cresce molto dobbiamo
fuggire non so come allora aspettatelo
pesta di fretta dove si rifletta bora.la
questa è l'unica cosa e mi è venuto in
mente ok penso che mi abbia visto al
meno che a meno che non sia cieco
ragazzi non so come cazzo fa non vedermi
non lo so metti un paio d'occhiali zio
perché non stai bene
vabbè comunque credo di averlo girato
quindi scappiamo di qua ragazzi non so
come ce la sto facendo ma ce la sto
facendo
dimmi che ce la posso fare uscire di qua
l'ascensore vero sì sì sì
mio dio togliti porca [ __ ] ragazzi
non ci posso credere
stiamo per uscire la sto posta di merda
e ancora laggiù vero non ci posso
credere libertà libertà libertà bye bye
bye bye voi così
mio zio tantissimo ragazzi è stata una
delle scene più violente che io non mi
arrendo cazzo ragazzi come può essere
qui berna togliti brutto stronzo esci di
qua è il mio ascensore c'è scritto papi
j
togliti ragazzi
ma meno poppa tutto quanto ma tutto
proprio ragazzi lo schiacciato e vi
serva da lezione se sfidate fa vj finite
delle sottilette in poche parole ragazzi
ce l'ho fatta non so come e pulsante
sinistro del mouse anche perfetto deve
uscire di sopra perché sono non va bene
io non uscirei da dove c'è il dottore
questo è sicuro senti zio
adesso che sei rimasto schiacciato ti
prenderei volentieri a pedate nel culo
ma non lo faccio per rispetto dei suoi
genitali anche se penso che non ce li
hai più ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta non
so come vediamo di uscire dal suo posto
di merda perché non ce la faccio
veramente più non penso sia alla fine di
outlast cioè non credo almeno penso non
lo so l'importante che non ci sia più
quel deficiente di prima e bosh amico ha
permesso vabbè comunque sia è meglio chi
è quello identificate uomo nero chi
cazzo è questo ragazzi a penso stia lo
zio fester grazie a dio sia
sopravvissuto ciao zio bevevo che quel
maniaco pagano ti avrebbe sventrato come
ha fatto con gli altri
raggiungi before he qui ci siamo quasi
grazie dio vedete che lo zio fester alla
fine cerca padre martin all'esterno
all'esterno deve uscire c'è un'uscita da
sto manicomio non ci posso credere
l'uscita dovrebbe essere di qua questa è
la cucina
cos [ __ ] chi cazzo sei tu fammi
uscire allora è questa e la cucina
trovati la tua nutella
ma passano a chiedere se vuole passare
cioè mio dio fa vj per favore ti sposti
no l'educazione è andato a [ __ ] nei
manicomi vabbè l'abbiamo capito comunque
per la cronaca tu sei bellissimo non
volevo dirtelo ma se veramente sexy
ragazzi usciamo di qua perché non ne
posso più
l'uscita era da queste parti non mi
ricordo dove di preciso oddio oddio non
ci credo non ci posso credere
siamo fuori bravi ragazzi concludo qui
l'episodio non è ancora finito out
avviamente ce ne sono ancora gli episodi
non siamo forse a metà non lo so
comunque ragazzi concludo più vivo è
vedrete continua nel prossimo episodio 6
video è piaciuto come solito lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video tratta una
descrizione se ne siete riusciti
iscrivetevi non ci rivediamo il prossimo
vinto bella ragazzi